all right up next is going to be Linda
in Wisconsin hi Linda how are you hi
Dave I'm great yeah I'm gonna
machine-gun you so don't run out of time
okay
what's your net worth our net worth is
about three million and what's that
invested in roughly it's invested in
retirement funds mutual funds
we've been self-employed our entire
careers so about one point know about
2.2 million of it is all investments
okay and what's their other million the
other million is our personal property
our commercial property we own the
office where my husband practices
surrealist son okay a little bit of
hunting land gotcha
and how old are you guys I am 55 my
husband is 59 okay and how much of this
money did you inherit the month oh those
are three million none of it
okay and what's your working income
average though your work lifetime
household in average well our average
income I would say has been between 150
and 250 thousand okay cool and career
field my husband is a dentist and I own
a retail Bridal and prom store okay cool
and what would what would you I'm sure
you have you got a four-year degree I do
in business and fashion and your GPA was
what 3.7 great okay and how much of this
money is due to you borrowing money to
invest
none of it we did barrel early in our
careers and found out we didn't sleep
well at night and paid everything off as
fast as we could very early very cool
well it's an honor to talk to you it's a
great story another one thank you for
calling in man absolutely amazing so 1.6
1.3 1.2 5 3 million in 1.6 and 3 million
those are the numbers not a single NFL
star not saying I wouldn't talk to one
if they called in not a single person in
this group was a crook and hear anybody
ripping people off none of them had the
wealth because they inherited it some of
them got a little bit of money here or
there most of the time after they were
already millionaires
none of them had what one had a 4.0
everybody else had a threes and twos and
their GPA you can do it that's the point
of this you do not let people tell you
you cannot win that's the point of this
it's called a Millionaire theme outline
you can do this don't believe the lies
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind